god damn you
and now without further ado the finalist
for the first annual reason video prize
are crony chronicles I want to be a
crony by Owen Brennan Justin Foulke and
Robert Perkins when I grow up I want to
work for the government and rig the
system I want to work for the IRS the
SEC video game of food trucks by Isaac
Reiss for the Institute of Justice the
council even called upon their Sears to
observe the food trucks every move it
just feels like an ankle bracelet as a
small business owner to have to have a
GPS tracking device monitor your every
whereabouts I pencil by drew Tidwell for
passing lane films you might think a
pencil is simple chances are you've been
using one since before you could even
read or write but just because it's
familiar doesn't mean it's simple
Obama that I used to know by Justin
Monticello for just new productions
Obama that I used to know what she
wanted let you cut me off made up like
it was once on ammo and we got nothing
relocation shouldn't be that hard to
strap the prisoners in on top of Rocky's
car top DHS checkpoint refusal by bad
Fels that's my business well it's our
business to ask are you do citizen or
you can ask that fun and you have to
answer wrong we have to continue until
you can either tell me well I don't have
to answer you because I have rights as
Americans or go ahead and pull over
there behind that other vehicle you do
me a favor yes no thanks
and now to announce the three winners
tonight I'd like to invite Freight Alevi
up to the Dyess feita and can levy are
among the biggest benefactors of reason
TV so thank you very much along with the
sorrel freedom trust who is also here
the third place winner of the reason
video prize for one thousand dollars is
Game of Thrones food crops produced by
Isaac briefs for the institute of dustin
and second place winner of the reason
video prize for two thousand dollars is
obama that i used to know produced by
justin monticello for justice production
first place winner of the reason video
prize for seven thousand dollars is I
pencil produced by Drew Tate well oh wow
I just like to thank reason for this
award it's definitely an honor I am very
humbled